did any of you ever as a kid grow up and
want to be a housewife no yes really you
did yes like even till now I'd want to
do like house like be a housewife but
like maybe work like two days from home
or something
no I was gonna say yesterday
yes there's Housewives she didn't say
Housewives but how many were raised you
won't what were you raised to be a
housewife like I grew up in southern
baptist and submission like a lot of
women think it's dirty I'm like this is
standard model that's like asking for
doors and windows on a car do you do you
feel like you're a race to be a
housewife
um
not like with my dad and things like
that as in I saw that growing up but I
my mum like taught me how to cook to
clean and things like that so that's
what I'm comfortable doing and then as
you get older and you realize you do
have to work and you're used to it you
think I would want to bring something to
the table as well like working and
intelligence and things like that but
also still want to but you're a
Housewives for the CEO of your
corporation in the company a lot of
women say I don't want to be a domestic
slave I want to have my own money that
CEO that's your daddy that's your sugar
daddy that's who you shaking it for yes
sir yes your man he's paying everything
for you and you think that's Freedom
when this man don't like they if they
have if they have to make Cuts in the
company you're out they don't care about
you there's nothing about you you're not
valuable and you have to compete in it
is tiresome and you're exhausted your
kids suffer your kids are are Buck Wild
like like I don't think people see the
consequences but I don't blame young
women I think it's a failure of older
women
who we have indoctrinated our younger
younger women you know Maggie and I like
I'm I'm 41 and Maggie is an older woman
and me
I know I blame older women
yeah we did we didn't said like we I
mean I personally did my mother did in
the women in my family have but I know
in large we have failed these younger
women and we've let them just run the
streets and we have not checked our
daughters I I let me catch my daughter
my mother today if I post a picture at
my age my mother is 74. I am 41. let me
post a picture where the dress is a
little too much short
my mother would text me and say you look
[__]
and I feel shame and embarrassment and I
feel like I failed my family I think
it's a failure of the family structure
my father he doesn't have to say
anything him and I won't talk for days
he's my best friend and I said that like
he's just like Mel like like your mother
told you what like you like and I think
a lot of women have not had the the love
of a family of of men
to to tell them the truth and and that's
why they hated Kevin Samuels because he
was a fatherly figure that told them the
truth and they didn't want to hear it
like your average your average hoe like
and you have whole activity and if you
want to get better you have to do better
but the the Rebellion no one's ever been
in your life to discipline you so it's
like who are you to tell me what to do
because you're you you never had to
discipline you can't even believe
someone would tell you the truth about
you but there was a love for you and he
wanted you to grow but that's even
that's why they celebrated his death
because now we're free to be hoeing and
nobody's going to hold us accountable
she was looking at me and calling me
Maggie
because I knew she met me but she's like
Maggie I'm Auntie Jenny and the other
thing is um when it comes to the old
people about raised to be a I was raised
to be a wife my mom I also my mom get up
early in the morning and do stuff and
cook stuff and even when my mom got
divorced with my dad I still kept it up
I started to go and you know visit my
dad did you make sure they've got his
food I remember washing his clothes by
hand you know and I I thought you know
what I want to do that I want to be a
housewife because
in in my day you had to wash things by
hand now you've got washing machines
people are making it sound like it's so
hard
being a housewife's a piece of piss
that's it you you work out your routine
and I've seen women do it where they can
I've improved it to probably like rush
around and make yourself do nothing all
day and you can rush around with all mod
cons you can get that house Tip Top get
everything sorted two hours before you
get some dinner cooked house clean
because you've got all the mod cons so
women are saying oh yeah I want to be a
housewife but I want I also want a job I
don't want that job you've got a job the
job is to look after your man your
children the house what more do you want
you've got the car you can go where you
like you can fool the man because what
all he cares is like you know get his
balls emptied and getting his belly full
how many people take a picture of their
house right now if I told you right now
take a picture of your house every room
in your house I want to see how it's
organized decorated and I want to see it
is it a hot ass mess is it about is it
does it look like a trap house is it
like a crash site is your mattress on
the floor is your it you're worried
about bag but your home where you dwell
you're in the street if you you live in
the streets if you're about that life
you're not taking care of a home you
don't really care what's going on in
there we've seen these videos on YouTube
and you have to say to yourself like I'm
not making a home like what man wants to
come home my you know in my home smells
ratchet a lot of women your pH balance
like and I'm just going to say this
because we're going to be out here we
out here right like we're talking about
sex work
like how many men right now you take
your panties off and they can smell them
away
could you not shower for a couple days
and your panties still smelling that's
just nice
yeah
you use that BV is banging why because
yeah vaginosis has passed and I'm not
putting as a shame but a lot of young
women your mothers have not taught you
how to even wash yourself properly
douche okay no it ain't even about you
shouldn't even do a douche like and
that's what I want to talk about that
because a lot of young women have not
been taught this and we've got to have
these conversations your your box is for
the street but your box
take go to the bathroom you take them
off let me as a woman I'll Stand in that
bed I go to the bathroom and I smell you
I come in the bathroom after you and I'm
smelling
[Laughter]
a lot of these women your ass stink
stink and you don't even you think this
is cute you don't wear perfume you think
you just spray some body spray you don't
even know how to clean you're not
hygienic let me tell you something I
ain't got to take a shower for a week
if I chose not to I would I will I
listen listen my mother because if she
taught me you come around my mother and
she's 74. she has no body odor from head
to toe she has no body hair
why because she was taught how to be a
woman right now it's about being sexual
but not how to be a actual woman and
have your womb clean your womb has been
ran through it's been it's it's Plan B
it's Planned Parenthood it's been ran
through so many it's so many sticks
inside those walls and I want to say
this in a way not to criticize you but
to understand
you have been degraded by the street the
the street has once your mind gone they
want you ran through with vaginosis they
want you going to the clinic they want
you taking the medication they want you
on Plan B why because the because your
mothers have failed you your fathers
have failed you the society has failed
you but there are women like me
like Pearl oxygen no I'm gonna say it
and Maggie The Substitute Teacher where
we say we love you we don't we know
you've been failed and it's not a
judgment on you we want you to win and
we're trying to give you the cheat code
so you don't have to be out here like
these other women and struggle
take this mess off you don't need all
this on you like like you got your nails
done your wig fixed you got all this
done I go to the bathroom after your ass
stink girl that BV is
BVT
I'm gonna say I want to say two things
is that when it comes to the All
stinkiness Size Doesn't Matter because
the skinny [__] is smell this is better
it does not matter
she smell perfect the young girl the
young lady next to the Irish lady I want
to know it's a joke because she was
there telling us like giving everybody
information and everybody else was
listening and you were killing yourself
laughing I want to know what was so
funny because I didn't get the joke I'm
Just a Gigolo no but I've just found a
little bit of it funny that's all so she
was she was talking you were just
rolling around giggling for no reason
um could you tell me specifics and I
could probably remember I'm talking
about
because Brittany Renner talked about how
she took she had three men down in one
week and she had a nasty yeast infection
chlamydia and you had gonorrhea no let's
not call it no it's not nice I don't
care what's nice
I'm not saying it's not nice if you
busting it open and you taking three
dicks down now like let's be adults like
there's nothing nice about you taking
three days
obviously you can catch BV without
having sex you can catch kind of stuff
to Camp stop the cat you can't stop that
I know you can but y'all are taking down
never been seen in the world before
BV was never this important because
women had a man and they were not
running the streets y'all got yeast
infections running up the streets like I
said I will take and I'm not trying to
be nasty but we can go to the bathroom
right now let's do it
[Music]
are you trying to do a taste test
no if we're talking about sex worker
we're gonna go that raw I feel like I
have to speak in that way and I don't
say it to put you down but understand
you have been failed as a woman and as a
young woman your mother has failed you
you were you you ran through your walls
are ran through and bust through and you
are dealing with diseases and everything
else and you're dealing with infections
and and when I go to the bathroom after
a young woman and your ass stink right
like I'm sorry like you I should never
go to the toilet I go to any restroom
right now I go to the mall
and your butts stink
s
you have been failed that that is up to
that is up to judgment
like I'm not saying you but you can't
judge if you're like like we are and I'm
just telling I'm just like good God girl
what is going on like and I say that
because who was your mama that did not
have you keeping yourself clean as a
woman guys I want the men to tell me
it's personal hygiene and smell of a
woman priority
is that she can be the baddest yeah most
women get custody and her it's a
non-negotiable it is nasty it it is some
stank down there non-negotiable but a
lot of young women they don't know how
to clean themselves I I have preteen
daughters
like do not play with me you were taking
two three showers a day a bath
soak I don't play those games how many
mothers in here so you putting you get
in the bath Epsom salt we putting a
little vinegar in there we're doing
whatever we have you will not walk out
this house without your deodorant
without being cleanly shaved without
having your body in order a lot of us
because our mothers were struggling
working whatever we were left to figure
it out on our own we go to YouTube and
find out vaginal care
but you're ready to bust it open on on
only fans and your box stink
so what would you say to people that
obviously
didn't have a very good figure growing
up but maybe they didn't get caught the
things I don't necessarily think it's
their fault yeah yeah they should have
taught themselves
what you say in hygiene and whatnot but
what if you grew up in a way that you
wasn't taught these things and again
it's not necessarily your fault but
you've had to learn yourself and you're
being judged for that okay is that young
lady a virgin who you
um I'd prefer not to answer that
question answer who taught you how to
have sex
what I was going to say was that you get
to an age when you're an adult and now
you're saying oh this person hasn't
taught me that that person's not saying
that personally for me
I have twerking classes but you don't
know how to clean clean your vags yeah
no that's that's true I'm just being
devil
what would you say to me it is
let's put a tender hand on it let's put
a tender hand on it we got fire and it's
not to anyone in this room
but what it is is we are upset with how
Society has brainwashed you
because we believe in all of you being
beautiful and we feel like they have
tried to brainwash you into something
that you were not never meant to be and
we feel like you've been failed and we
have to come hard because Society comes
hard at you and tries to tell you who to
be and we want you to win we want you to
be wise we want you to not have to be
out here selling and opening your
vaginal walls in order to make a dollar
that is a failure of your parents that
is a failure of society that is a
failure of your education and is a
failure of who you are in your morals
it's a failure but guess what but once
you acknowledge that we all have to come
to a place of failure men have to do it
every day men are told they ain't ish
men are told if you're broken Dusty we
don't want no scrubs if you're short if
you're this body positivity only exists
for women yeah where is the men on the
cover of of Cosmo and all these
magazines so men are used to these hard
talks so if you haven't been raised
around men my father you know he didn't
call me Princess he didn't call me queen
he didn't call me beautiful when I was
born as a baby I was I was a little
chubby thing he called me meatball I was
a meatball As I Grew it went from
meatball to meat
and meaty and big meaty and fat meaty to
this day my father's like what's up fat
meaty and he would tell me when my
thighs was looking extra thick and he
said you ain't like that you got a
little extra look at that but he would
say it in a way and he trained me in a
way to to say or if I if if I didn't put
deodorant on that day yeah my father
said
like my father would tell me you stank
guys if I put my underwear on the floor
in the bathroom my father would tell my
mother you better get that girl or if I
left the bathroom and my butt stink my
father would tell my mother you better
put her in the tub well because back
then they cared about shame but now it's
like we live in this culture that's so
woke that you can't shame you can't
shame anyone for anything some of the
best things that's ever happened to me
in my life is because someone shamed me
and this is not about shame to put you
down like shame is about you know what
wow like what I thought there I have
been shamed about many things
and I only say this because I want you
to win like this isn't to put you down
is to give you a cheat code of what men
want all these women will call me a pick
me they think I'm pandering to men no I
am who I am and if men choose me the men
y'all want the Ballers and all of that
they're coming to women who have a sound
mind with clean draws and they and even
older because they they see that and
what we're saying to you is we want to
pick up that torch and I do believe even
my Improvement that I have to do because
I come so hard and I realize it can come
like a freight train that's something I
have to improve I have to hear if you
guys give me feedback say if you said it
this way I I could receive it better
so I even will say even here live like I
am I need to be accountable can I come
better in my Approach yes I absolutely
I'm a work in progress so the day I take
my last breath but I say it's not out of
hate for you I hate what has happened to
you has has deceived you because I think
I think every woman on this panel today
is beautiful and has like unique
features and it has something to offer
and to can win and to find happiness but
can every woman here today say would you
be happy doing only fans would you be
happy having to sell and show your body
or would you want a man who loves you
nurtures you protects you or men around
you who say this is a valuable like
don't play with her like that's that's
that's our like like you don't like you
can mess with these chicks over here but
that's Wifey right here we don't you
don't you don't do that like over here
with her and that's how men treat me
even at my age having two children at 41
like it I I'm protected so I don't ever
say does a man protect and provide of
course that's all I've ever experienced
even been through divorce
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible